So we've covered ways to
communicate between machines, but
how do we format the sets of information
that we want to send and receive?
This message formatting layer contains
the languages that address this concern.
These protocols focus mainly on the data
structures that contain the information
we want to communicate,
like the protocols in the other layers.
There are several implementations
already out there, but
the most two common formats are XML and
JSON.
XML stands for
the extensible markup language.
It looks very similar to HTML and
is readable by humans and machines.
JSON stands for
JavaScript object notation.
It was designed to resemble JavaScript
code, and has attribute value pairs,
making it also very easy
to read from the human eye.
With all these technologies out there,
we've got to do some side-by-side
comparisons in order to make the choice
that best suits our web application.